[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la ola de ataques yihadistas que vive
francia ahora que se cumplen
precisamente cinco años de aquel
noviembre negro en parís para ello me
acompañan en este estudio de lisa barra
compañera de la redacción de américa
latina de recibien venido a melissa a la
carlos arnau béranger de la redacción
inglesa de reciben venido a ver buenos
días carlos y en dúplex contamos con la
periodista aleja alexandra ágil
especialista en yihadismo y autora del
libro en el vientre de la 'yihad'
alexandra qué tal
el terror vuelve a francia cinco años
después de aquellos ataques de noviembre
de 2015 hoy en primera plana
[Música]
pues se cumplen cinco años de los
atentados del noviembre negro en parís
lo recuerdan tres comandos atacando
simultáneamente la sala bataclán los
bares de un distrito céntrico y el
estadio de francia con un resultado de
130 personas muertas unos atentados que
tuvieron de precedentes se lo recuerdan
a los del semanario satírico charlie
hebdo y que continuaron a su vez con
otros atentados como el de niza de 2016
un lustro después de aquello la amenaza
yihadista pues sí ahí ya no hay un
califato terrenal para el estado
islámico digamos pero si el terreno de
lo digital y el terrorismo ahora
denominado low cost de bajo coste el que
se basta de un simple cuchillo para
sembrar el horror y lo hemos visto
durante estas semanas en varias
ocasiones aquí en francia desde la
decapitación del profesor samuel para ti
por enseñar las caricaturas de mahoma en
clase al ataque que dejó tres muertos en
la iglesia notre damme de niza el
presidente macrón toma la ofensiva ahora
en varios campos como la seguridad en
fronteras o la persecución de
asociaciones islamistas de esta
situación vamos a hablar hoy en el
programa pero antes vamos a repasar
algunas portadas como hacemos
la dps europa frente a la amenaza
terrorista tras los ataques en francia y
en austria diario la co a esos otros
lugares de radicalización como prisiones
transportes públicos hospitales o
seguridad privada dice el rotativo que
la radicalización islamista concierne a
agentes públicos empleados en estos
ámbitos diario libération izquierda
islam crisis de conciencia explica el
rotativo como la izquierda tiene tantos
problemas para articular un mensaje
claro sobre la laicidad en francia por
miedo a contaminarse con la islamofobia
pero melissa han pasado cinco años de
2015 esta ola de ataques que vive
francia y que también ha golpeado a bien
en las últimas semanas qué
características tiene y en qué es
diferente de aquel entonces de 2015
bueno la primera impresión obviamente es
que uno siente que se hay cierta
descomposición no desde el aparato
financiero y del aparato logístico de lo
que era en 2015 el terrorismo y los
ataques de parís por ejemplo
en la época estaba organizado por la
otrora organización estado islámico
hoy tenemos la impresión de que el
yihadismo tiene que recurrir a
individuos aislados a individuos
- armados menos financiados y lo vimos
justamente en confianza antónovich con
el asesinato de summer para ti y también
lo vimos en niza son individuos que no
están en seriamente en el radar de las
autoridades francesas y sin embargo las
autoridades francesas han sido muy muy
activas porque se sabe por ejemplo las
últimas cifras es que 61 ataques
terroristas han sido frustrados en los
últimos cinco años
claro en plena pandemia alexandra el
terrorismo yihadista vuelve a atacar en
europa pero es muy distinto del que
teníamos hace unos años que era capaz de
provocar de provocar decenas de muertos
con atentados más sofisticados y
perpetrados con hombres con experiencia
a veces ligados a grupos internacionales
cómo funciona este ahora denominado
terrorismo de low cost de bajo coste
bueno vemos por ejemplo con los tentados
como el que comentaba a la compañera de
samuel partir del profesor que hay
atentados que efectivamente que la
conmoción y el impacto de ataque es
común como esa decapitación de dirección
cuando perder un poco el sentido
analítico no en realidad los datos lo
que nos dicen es que el último atentado
a gran escala con una preparación real
una preparación previa con una
estrategia previa fue del 2017 y fue el
de barcelona
entonces estamos ante un terrorismo low
cost pues lo que nos dicen los datos
también es que es una mutación constante
no lo vemos con viena por ejemplo vemos
que en este nuevo en esta nueva forma de
terrorismo lo que se lo que se deja ver
es que se está adaptando a las
circunstancias que las estamos viendo
las cárceles francesas sobrepobladas
estamos viendo que habrá 500 entre entre
150 y 300 presos que van a salir de la
cárcel en los próximos tres años nos
estamos viendo que las cartas bancarias
francesas siguen sin estar preparadas
sus propios agentes penitenciarios
para prevenir una radicalización de los
presos que han entrado por delitos
comunes y lo que vemos ahora mismo con
el tema de la amenaza de la amenaza de
low cost es que es menos previsible es
menos previsible porque no necesita de
una preparación y claro cuando detectar
a personas
y radicalizadas es más complejo cuando
el ataque que preparan no necesita de
muchos medios no necesitan mucho apoyo
logístico no obstante es importante
recordar que 6.000 jóvenes europeos se
marcharon y fueron los estudios
suficientemente atraídos se dieron
situaciones atraídos por uno por un
proyecto que hoy ese aparato
propagandístico no consigue no consigue
atraerlos la misma manera
esta ola de ataques a hernán en el fondo
confirman que el proyecto yihadista
nunca desapareció pese a las derrotas
del próximo oriente cómo funciona el
llamado ahora califato digital digamos
que eso se ha trasladado el terrenal a
un califato digital si es que la palabra
califato históricamente significa un
territorio geográfico que sea
en bagdad de la época de antes o en
siria había extremistas y terroristas
que siempre quería establecer un
califato un califato lo que pasó es que
lo que pasa es que ahora no hay más un
terreno geográfico geográfico asociado
con el califato ahora es solamente en
'twitter' el espacio se ha vuelto
virtual no hay un espacio físico
entonces eso es por la primera vez que
estamos viendo que un movimiento una
idea extremista no está asociado más a
un territorio geográfico podemos hablar
de la segunda guerra mundial podemos
hablar de
muchos eventos terroristas que ha pasado
en el mundo históricamente siempre ha
sido asociado con un territorio
geográfico entonces si podemos hablar de
un califato digital y la que no hay más
territorio para defender es solamente la
ideología para defender repasemos los
perfiles en los últimos atacantes que
han sembrado el terror aquí en francia
un paquistaní de 25 años que llevaba dos
años en francia un checheno de 18 años
que había llegado a este país de pequeño
y se había educado digamos en la escuela
francesa un tunecino de 21 años que
acababa de desembarcar en el continente
por la ruta de los migrantes en el
mediterráneo no estaban fichados por los
servicios de inteligencia usaron
cuchillos para atacar esto es un poco el
perfil común que hemos tenido hay un
denominador común en este tipo de
perfiles que de esta ola de ataques no
veréis claro y el denominador común
también es como le decíamos ahora no
está todo ese aparato logístico pero si
sigue la determinación del espíritu
yihadista no es decir qué
a ver la cuestión de la simbólica muy
fuerte es decir el querer ir y cometer
actos barbáricos para impactar y
alimentar un espectáculo en las redes
sociales entonces es un punto común que
es el hecho de buscar el símbolo el
espectáculo y buscar esa fascinación de
la violencia que todos estos seres
tienen en común y que lo van a ser
cuchillo en mano antes cuando repasamos
las portadas alexandra veamos esa de la
coa que decía cuando habla de nuevos
nichos y hablaba de empleados de
servicios públicos lo cual es bastante
inquietante no empleados que te pueden
trabajar en la red de ferrocarriles en
hospitales en prisiones tú hacías
referencia hace unos momentos es
bastante claro es muy difícil combatir a
ese enemigo que está tan dentro de la
sociedad francesa no
bueno el problema aquí radica me voy a
comprar solamente en el tema de las
partes les me parece muy interesante que
lo pongas en valor
ahora mismo francia en 2017 recuerdo que
cuando cuando hablábamos de cuántos
presos se habían radical dentro de la
cárcel funciona el lugar en el que se
supone que llegan a cumplir sobre ese
caso precisamente eran delitos comunes
se hablaba de alrededor de 1.200 presos
comunes que se habían radicalizado en la
cárcel a pesar de no haber sido
condenados por el terrorismo ahora ya se
ha acercado un poco más en ese círculo y
ahora ya se habla de 500 presos
condenados por terrorismo y alrededor de
500 que sí se han radicalizado dentro de
la cárcel que ha ocurrido que han
empezado a acercar un poco el término y
han empezado a distinguir entre el
rigorismo
y radicalización violenta es uno de los
grandes retos que tiene francia es
precisamente comprender qué es lo que
ellos entienden por radicalización antes
de intentar entablar procesos de
desradicalización es muy complicado que
todos los planes de prevención de la
radicalización que se llevan a cabo pues
en lugares como instituciones
penitenciarias
sean evaluados si es imposible saber
exactamente de qué manera falla o
funciona en tanto en cuanto el éxito
depende de un no evento es decir claro
esos presos van a salir de la cárcel y
nos no existe una forma de saber si su
desradicalización se puede probar porque
se han insertado en la sociedad porque
tiene una inserción sociolaboral es muy
complicado medir el éxito de estos
programas se separan el gran problema de
la prevención de la radicalización y
especialmente en francia es cómo se mide
si está funcionando
la publicación de nuevo a principios de
septiembre de las caricaturas de mahoma
en charlie hebdo coincidiendo con el
inicio del juicio a los presuntos
cómplices de los atentados ha circulado
en estar en las redes como como el nuevo
argumento digamos de estos terroristas
armado melissa este es el gran argumento
que tienen ahora los radicalizados una
especie de victimismo a partir de esas
caricaturas
yo diría abrir ti mismo de fachada pero
en realidad es oportunismo porque lo que
se busca en realidad es la oportunidad
mediática
por ejemplo en este momento o durante
todo caso entre 2015 y ahora salvo en
algunos momentos muy precisos el ojo
mediático estaba focalizado en la
desigualdad social los chalecos
amarillos el clima las mujeres y hoy en
la pandemia lo que bueno coincide
también con la debilitación un poco del
grupo estado islámico pero en 2020
inició también el juicio en el caso ya
aliento y también eso coincidió con la
reaparición la redifusión de caricaturas
religiosas caricaturas del profeta del
islam por parte también de yabalía bdo y
eso fue como la excusa perfecta para que
el foco mediático estaba ahí exacto era
la excusa perfecta para para volver a
atacar con esa
la victimización y estaba la brecha hace
un mes entre el momento en que en
francia entró en vigor el el toque de
queda y el confinamiento pues hubo la
brecha perfecta para cometer el atentado
de confianza antónovich y el atentado de
denis en ese momento es lo que se busca
en realidad no es decir estamos
defendiendo el islam lo que los
yihadistas quieren en realidad es el
poder que ofrece el miedo en la gente en
unos momentos le doy la palabra ar nada
vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa en estos
momentos sin sida volvemos aquí en
primera plana de recibe france24
[Música]
el gobierno alemán explicó que son muy
alentadores los avances presentados por
el consorcio entre facer y my own t que
en su vacuna contra el coronavirus y
mostró su satisfacción en particular por
el hecho de que para jon t que sea una
empresa alemana aunque también las
autoridades en este país aseguraron que
sus avances no significan necesariamente
que la vacuna vaya a ser entregada muy
pronto de hecho las autoridades alemanas
esperan que la vacuna pueda ser
entregada a los alemanes a principios
del próximo año ya sea por ese consorcio
o por otros y por esa razón ya empezaron
las preparaciones específicas según el
gobierno alemán se espera que la vacuna
vaya a ser entregada en 60 centros
especializados alrededor del país y una
comisión establecida para tal efecto
determinó que muy probablemente se le
vaya a dar prioridad primero a las
personas que estén en grupos de alto
riesgo seguidos por las personas que
trabajan en el sector de salud y quienes
están en profesiones consideradas como
relevantes para la vida pública como por
ejemplo los policías o los profesores
[Música]
la eficacia de la vacuna rusa contra el
coronavirus es del 92% según los
primeros resultados la vacuna haya
atravesado sus dos primeras fases y
ahora se encuentra inmensa en la tercera
más de 16.000 rusos han recibido ya las
dos primeras dosis necesarias de esta
vacuna por la cual ya se han interesado
varios países latinoamericanos pero
también turquía que se ha ofrecido a
ayudar en su producción en masa la
sputnik 5 se administra en dos etapas en
un intervalo de 21 días entre una y otra
está en marcha una segunda vacuna y el
presidente ruso vladimir putin ha dicho
que rusia está a punto de registrar su
tercera vacuna contra la cob y 19
putin ha dicho que está dispuesto a
cooperar con otros países en materia de
vacunación aunque ha advertido contra la
politización de estos procesos
lucia de momento se resiste a cerrar
todo el país y pone todas sus esperanzas
en una amplia campaña de vacunación
[Música]
aunque la fase final de los ensayos
clínicos de cuatro vacunas chinas aún no
ha concluido se sabe que cientos de
miles de ciudadanos del país asiático
han sido inoculados con ellas esta
precampaña de vacunación que arrancó en
verano está destinada principalmente a
militares oa ciudadanos chinos que
tienen que trabajar o estudiar en el
extranjero se desconocen por el momento
tanto la efectividad real como los
efectos secundarios y el régimen chino
además ha prohibido hablar con los
medios a aquellos que las han recibido
los fabricantes sino pharmacy novak
cansino por su parte aseguran que sus
productos son seguros al tiempo que
muchos expertos advierten del peligro de
comenzar a administrar vacunas a gran
escala cuando aún no han concluido esos
ensayos clínicos cabe recordar que una
vez que terminen esas pruebas chinas se
ha comprometido a vender a varios países
de latinoamérica estas vacunas algo que
puede actuar como un impulso diplomático
en un momento en el que la imagen
exterior del país asiático no es la
mejor
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
seguimos en primera plana de radio
france internacional y france 24 esta
semana ponemos el foco en la nueva ola
de ataques de perfil yihadista que vive
francia ahora justo que se cumplen 5
años de los atentados de noviembre negro
de noviembre de 2015 si lo recuerdan en
la sala bataclán y en los bares de un
distrito céntrico a quien parece que
dejaron 130 personas muertas que a
través de tres comandos diferentes
terroristas
hablando de las de la nueva ola de
ataques antes de la pausa estábamos
hablando de ese relato de victimismo
arnau por la ofensa de las caricaturas
de mahoma ese es el gran argumento para
potenciar ahora mismo este tipo de
ataques que vive francia en esta nueva
ola y yo pienso que como decía melissa
grita no solamente es el victimismo es
una excusa
por la información que circulan en las
redes sociales ellos solamente necesitan
una una información que sea verdadera
que sea falsa para lanzar para lanzar un
efecto de pánico
dentro de la dentro de la gente dentro
de ese califato digital
y ellos necesitan solamente una excusa
cualquiera para hacer sus actos claro
el juicio del charlie hebdo es muy
simbólico para ellos y yo también pienso
que hay aquí una de verdad 12 culturas
que nos entienden de verdad porque por
ejemplo charlie hebdo porque hablamos de
charly gente porque hay una cosa muy
esencial en francia que es el humor
francés el humor francés no es un humor
muy fácil a entender
y también los ritos para alguna para
algunos los ritos religiosos de algunas
religiones y del islam extra extremistas
no es fácil para los que no son
musulmanes para entender y yo pienso
también más que el victimismo más que
como la excusa para ir matar también hay
ss2 mundos que no se alcanza a
comprender a comprender qué es
alessandra gone alessandra investigado
mucho las redes yihadistas las familias
ha hablado con madres con familiares de
los que un día decidieron enrolarse con
el estado islámico al estante aclaró el
tiempo pasa el estado islámico
físicamente ya no está ahí pero cuáles
han sido tus sensaciones cuando te has
vuelto a poner en contacto con esos
familiares cuando has intentado volver a
saber de sus vidas con el paso del
tiempo
pues sigo en contacto con las familias
investigado en otra línea y además
centrada en las cárceles y en las madres
que tienen a sus hijos dentro de estas
cárceles por eso precisamente hacía
referencia al caso de las prisiones
francesas los temores de estas madres
que tienen a los hijos retornados de
silvia o irak son los mismos que los de
las instituciones penitenciarias en
realidad yo sí los mismos que tiene el
gobierno francés con esas instituciones
penitenciarias y es como voy a medir que
cuando mi hijo salga de la cárcel dentro
de diez o quince años no va a cometer
otro atentado ese es el mayor viendo que
estas madres tienen ya no es tanto la
inserción sino el propio el propio miedo
a que aquí nadie puedo asegurar que lo
que es estación dentro de las cárceles
francesas funcione y por otro lado
no hay que olvidar que no sería la
primera vez
estando en francia como ha sucedido en
otros momentos de la historia en las
familias de las personas radicalizadas
están creando redes fuera de las
cárceles son redes de apoyo que si bien
es cierto que no se no se puede
demostrar que estas redes de apoyo son
son redes de apoyo familiares es una
hermana que viaja a la cárcel que está a
300 400 kilómetros y va con la madre o
el padre de otro preso yihadista esto no
significa que estén creando redes
yihadistas jones y se están creando
redes que están continuando y continúan
perpetuando un discurso paralelo y que
se enraízan un poco en esa versión de
los gestos que no siempre coincide con
la realidad es muy complicado también
cuando se habla con la familia de un
yihadista que esa familia haga haga un
poco la diferencia de lo que realmente
sucedió con la radicalización de su hijo
y nos está acompañando lo suficiente
para recuperar a esas familias y se han
dado casos de hermanos radicalizados por
los propios yihadistas a distancia por
porque no se está
y haciendo ese ninguno había persiste a
día de hoy esos casos de radicalización
a distancia de hermanos que radicalizan
todavía no sé si tienes información
ahora ahora mismo si esto todavía
funciona
bueno esto funcionan tanto en cuanto a
las hermandades esto lo vemos muchísimos
casos de yihadistas que han radicalizado
sus propios hermanos los vemos con el
caso de los yihadistas de barcelona
esto sigue siga estando de actualidad en
tanto en cuanto el yihadismo sigue
siendo una ideología que se puede
transmitir y que se transmite el caso de
barcelona es el más el que nos puede
servir de ejemplo de cómo esa confianza
y esas redes de confianza sirven de
escenario perfecto de escenario un poco
macabro para a través de la confianza y
a través de esas relaciones
las ideologías que así se haga por
mimetismo esa radicalización entre
hermanos entre primos y entre familiares
y bueno matrón ha lanzado una ofensiva
contra el islamismo radical tanto dentro
de francia como a nivel internacional
con numerosas medidas algunas de las que
ya hemos sido conociendo como la
formación de imanes a nivel local a que
en francia o cerrar asociaciones
islamistas que fomenten discursos de
odio a veces disfrazadas de ongs
porque esto no se ha hecho hasta ahora
quizás sea la pregunta es decir qué
dificultades que entrañaba para que
macro no haya tardado años en elaborar
su llamada ley contra el separatismo
islamista bueno justamente el
separatismo islamista ya de por sí macro
no empezó a poner el dedo encima a
principios realmente de este año no o
sea se esperó hasta 2020 porque bueno
primero que todo porque 2015 macrón
todavía no era presidente de francia y a
partir de 2015 se empezaron a elaborar
leyes por el mandato precedente de
honshu a blondie su gobierno y no
empezaron realmente a ser adoptadas y no
están mediados de 2017 que pasó también
entre entretanto es una relativa calma
no de atentados terroristas en el suelo
francés y no se reactivó la cuestión de
la seguridad sino hasta principios de
2020 cuando se recordaron también los
los cinco años de los atentados de
charlie hebdo que pasa ahora
por un lado está la opinión popular es
decir lo que le puede o no pedir a la
sociedad francesa a maco y por otro lado
está el aparato jurídico que es más
complejo de lo que se podría creer es
decir hablábamos de centros islámicos
que van a ser disueltos prohibidos
jurídicamente es más complicado que eso
y la ley francesa protege también mucho
la libertad de culto no como la libertad
de expresión pero también protege la
libertad de culto entonces todas esas
medidas son muy difíciles de implementar
y ahorita en diciembre van a entrar un
va a ser presentado a los a los
ministros un proyecto de ley justamente
para cerrar un poco más ese cerco france
anunciaba la semana pasada que duplicaba
su vigilancia en fronteras y pide más
control a europa incluso hallado decir
macro en una refundación del tratado
schengen denunció entre otras cosas el
desvío del derecho de asilo que es
utilizado por traficantes y por redes
arnau europa ha sido demasiado laxa y
han faltado controles yo pienso que
totalmente desde mi opinión pero si hay
un pienso que europa ha sido de más
y yo tengo una opinión sobre esto es que
yo llamo eso la general genera
generalización del desconocido por
ejemplo una cultura extranjera que sea
antiguamente por ejemplo la cultura
oriental o la cultura de áfrica
aquí en europa había una una tendencia
de generalizar toda la gente de nuestra
cultura como que por ejemplo hablamos
por ejemplo de los migrantes había una
tendencia que que desea los migrantes
son los pobres que vienen están en
situación muy muy mala y había otra
tendencia no los todos los migrantes
zonas están yendo aquí para para cómo
hacer caer a esta civilización esas son
dos cosas extremismos 222 opiniones
extremistas dentro de los migrantes como
dentro de los franceses como dentro de
todo el pueblo del mundo hay cosas
buenas y hay cosas malas hay gente buena
y hay gente mala
si no hay filtro en las fronteras de
europa y deja entrar todo el mundo no
solamente están dejando entrar gente que
va a causar daño a este este país este
continente
están dejando entrar gente también buena
que están siendo perjudicados por
es esa otra gente que tiene intenciones
magníficas que la izquierda no haya
denunciado esto
ha hecho el caldo de cultivo a la
extrema derecha es decir que la
izquierda haya tenido tantos problemas
para articular un mensaje
contra este tipo de esto
ha propiciado que el epen tuvieron
bulevar a su disposición por cierto que
es un argumento histórico de la derecha
conservadora en europa que se trata de
cerrar fronteras para permitir pues para
impedir que el enemigo exterior entre no
en la cosa que eso perdemos un poco el
foco no porque la amenaza es endógena es
decir está presente ya dentro del
territorio el califato como lo decías
digital viaja más fácilmente por
internet que por el mediterráneo y
también para mimetizar un poco también
esto
este año hemos tenido francia un año
bastante sangriento no en términos de
atentados y sin embargo pues europa
nunca ha estado tan cerrada por culpa de
la pandemia en este momento los procesos
los trámites de pedido de asilo están
suspendidos entonces efectivamente
siempre ha sido un argumento de la
derecha de cerrar las fronteras pero el
otro lado como lo decía la izquierda
también está ante un dilema porque sobre
todo la izquierda francés es un sector
muy dividido y entre dejar la libertad
de expresión permitir también la
densidad en el país y evitar la
discriminación de ciertas minorías
religiosas no saben muy bien cómo
posicionarse de sandra en los últimos
minutos del programa me gustaría
referirme a la efeméride de la que hoy
nombramos el programa esos 5 años de los
atentados de parís desde noviembre de
2015 pero me gustaría hacerlo desde el
recuerdo de las emociones
y si os a poco esta fecha i aleixandre
empiezo por ti que es lo primero que se
ven a la cabeza no tienen por qué yo
creo que todos recordamos un poco donde
estábamos en aquel momento por aquel
entonces
y pues yo me había comprado un billete
de avión para ir a ver a mi familia
españa me había comprado el billete de
avión el día 13 por la mañana y volvía
al 14 y así fue
y bueno yo estaba estaba conduciendo
cuando cuando me sonó el teléfono me
contaron lo que estaba con lo que estaba
pasando tenía todo en parís
absolutamente todo tenía muchísimos
amigos muchísimo amor pero llevaba casi
8 años viviendo allí y el recuerdo que
tengo es de caos absoluto y de
preparación para cubrir al día siguiente
contratados nada más llegar y bueno
empezamos a hablar con las víctimas de
bueno con las familias que tenían dentro
de esa ola de atentados no a personas
afectadas y a partir de ahí empezó pues
todo todo el trayecto que terminó en el
libro y continuó con más proyectos en
esta en este sentido entonces se guardó
un recuerdo muy sentido y muy amargo un
breve recuerdo de aquellas fechas dos
segundos estaba en el sava 100 metros
desde la bataclán yo vi gente corriendo
y allí vi gente saliendo el bataclán
cubierto de sangre
pues con ese recuerdo de lo que fue hace
cinco años el terror aquí en parís nos
despedimos esta semana en primera plana
volvemos la próxima semana muchísimas
gracias